cigarette un nouveau grand un nouveau
grand du nouveau rire sérieux mais les
gens dans la rue je sais pas s'ils sont
encore tous convaincus à la je me doute
que je vois venir le trou là je veux
venir comme sebha fille qui pose la
question je m'ennuie c'est bien sérieux
on va voir laurent baffie que star de
star
vulgaire vulgaire carrément vulgaire ça
vous choque son côté pétomane p thomas
louis aussi oui oui vous le trouvez
comment vent à ces hideuses il m'amuse
mais dans le mauvais sens
vous trouvez grossier ou vulgaires il
est grossier il est vulgaire il est
ambitieux il est pas à sa place je n'ai
qu'une hâte c'est qui disparaît je
trouve ça triste ouille ça fait hurler
de rire des millions de français à moi
je jure que par sa série en fait oui
retrouver grossier ou vulgaires je
trouve grossier plus qu'un vulgaire et
ça vous fait rire ça me fait rire il ya
des limites mais oui vous êtes très pipi
caca vous même oui chaussée pipi caca
une belle saloperie parce qu'il prend
les gens pour des imbéciles ne vous fait
pas rien non pas du tout fait rire
vulgaire grossier
medica star des stars longue date fils
ali ben non j'ai beaucoup aimé ce qui
est dit le deuxième chien mais rien même
les chaises n'a pas aimé du tout dit
dans ces marais c'est grave ça fait que
c'est dû à ces émissions qui a fait sur
tf1 mais je sais pas je me rends pas
compte je suis consterné jean-marie
s'arrête pas le métier tout de suite à
mon avis il ya un truc avant il ya dray
j'espère at on agit de qui parles ces
gens là voilà trente quand en plus il
est pas beau je ne peux pas l'être moi
je vois pas mon pauvre jean marie si
c'était toi dont on parlait à l'asie
allez-y dites le moi des bombes à
regarder mais non on va regarder la
réponse est la propre petit téléviseur
la réponse est là le qui parle et on
qu'est ce que je pense de michel
charasse
oui oui jean louis péries rouiba bon
comics pour vous assez ans et vous
madame de michel charasse je préfère me
taire merci vous fait rire il m'amuse
mais à lui ma vie change
que pensez vous arrêter vous voilà que
pensez vous de michel charasse j'ai pas
très envie de répondre c'est très
ennuyeux ou pas qu'il vous fait rire oui
me fasse rire en fait un monsieur que
pensez vous de michel charasse
pour moi c'est une belle saloperie plus
tôt
plus tôt
tu parle pas on parle pas de plus tôt là
on parle de michel charasse les
corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux